well now an attempted military coup in
Turkey was quashed by its government
this weekend after a bloody night which
left at least two hundred and sixty five
people dead and thousands more injured
three thousand soldiers have been
arrested in two thousand seven hundred
judges suspended President Erdogan of
Turkey says those responsible will be
punished and the way that punish could
sit uncomfortably for some European
countries already concerned by turkeys
human rights record well I'm join now by
turkeys deputy chief of mission here in
the UK Jen ishik and a very good morning
to you mr. issue can let me ask you
first of all we've seen those pictures
in our morning papers today of soldiers
stripped soldiers being being whipped
and and beaten will they be treated
those that did rebel against the
government will they be treated properly
taken through courts of law and been
given jus judicial process well let me
start by expressing explaining what
happened what happened the situation
which unfolded in Turkey on Friday was
an attempted coup to overthrow the
democratically elected government there
was a military movement including in the
cities of Istanbul and Ankara which was
not within the normal military chain of
command following the immediate
evaluations it was understood that this
was a coup they attempted coup by a
group of military personnel from various
ranks I mean we can't we kind of got
this nice even a statement they're
prepared but we kind of got that far
what we wondering now is the coup having
failed is there as a as a democratic
country with proper legal process what
will happen to those thousands of people
now that we've seen some of them in the
military some of them judges what will
happen to them in terms of their
punishment well turkey turkey is a
democratic secular republic it has the
it is governed by the rule of law and
this attempted coup to overthrow the
democratically elected government has
failed we have seen for the first time
airplanes helicopters that were used
that were bought with the money of the
people it
for the first time in deterrent in the
Republic's history they were turned
against the people they were turned
against the Parliament that were turned
against government's be harsh treatment
then I see I can imply from what you're
saying there you know the some
discussion that these the treasonable
acts the times the death penalty could
be reintroduced in Turkey these are
these are these are very serious
offenses this is treason this is
treachery what will happen is there will
be investigation there will be
investigations as to how this happened
who did it and of course everything
right now points to the fact that this
was a military group from various ranks
not within the chain of command it
wasn't supported within the chain of
chain of command by the commander's but
they were loyal to to a terrorist group
of fatal aculon what will happen is
there will be an investigation there
will be and of course they will be tried
and they will receive the punishment
they the first response given to them
was from the people the people acted in
solidarity in unity they acted with the
states with the Prime Minister the
president the government and they they
undermined this attempted coup and the
government and the President and and
everyone elected what was was really it
prevented the coup absolutely and and
are you in turkey aware that obviously
you have a long-standing application to
join the European Union that the way
this coup is dealt with will be what's
very carefully by those assessing
turkeys fitness to join the European
Union I let me answer that question but
please don't think that I was dodging
the previous question on the death
penalty the the people are furious they
have had tanks pointed at them warplane
sport and pointed at them they've had
helicopters points at the police
officers civilians are all killed they
of course emotions are running high and
they have made their calls now it's of
course up to any Parliament that is in
touch with the people of course the
Turkish Parliament is no different to
listen to those calls and to evaluate
the situation we have a functioning
Parliament they were yesterday together
in
emergency session and they adopted a at
a joint declaration so obviously this
Parliament will heed the they will
listen to to the people so there is a
possibility the death penalty could be
reintroduced it needs to be evaluated it
needs to be about if the people call for
it then the politicians will have to
evaluate it in a parliament just like in
any democratic society as for the EU
turkey turkey is a long-standing
candidate of the European Union to join
the European Union this is a strategic
choice that was made a long time ago
turkey is is a it's a strong member of
NATO it's it's it's it's a modern
secular developing democracy I don't
think but the very to answer I'm sorry
wait time is limited but the very to
answer is there you know have a bearing
upon each other if the EU then witnesses
if the death penalty is reintroducing
the EU witnesses turkey shooting and
hanging generals and judges it's not
going to say I'd say would be on the
plus side of turkeys application I'm not
saying that the death penalty will be
reintroduced I'm saying that this was
abolished by choice by turkey with with
with with the support of the people a
long time ago we have the for example
the the ringleader of of the terrorist
organization PKK for example terrorist
organization that's also prescribed here
in the UK he was captured back in
nineteen ninety nine I think we we were
strong and resilient and resisted all I
suppose wish or maybe a feeling to
impose the death penalty even on him but
there I mean there are wider questions
as well remaining here about the way
president died one and the authorities
deal with the aftermath of this there
are some saying that well because it
turned out to be such a weak attempt to
overthrow him that it actually plays in
president earlier ones favoring that
economic move even further to erode
human rights and to maintain his grip
increase his grip on Turkey I I'm not
quite sure if I agree with the weaker
tent
there were warplanes there were there
were helicopters the Turkish radio
television was seized by by means of
arms and by what I can only describe is
psychological warfare media outlets were
seized but the the people stood up they
rose they hit they took the streets they
stood in front of tanks and people
people kill two people died there was
there was a there was a you know the
press and media for example gave a
lesson in democracy I don't think this
was a week or or or any small attempt
this was a very serious event it will be
it will be investigated and they will
receive the punishment okay mystery she
could see thank you very much indeed gem
issue there Turkey's deputy chief of
mission here in the UK